across the valley agencies are teaming
up to provide domestic abuse training
mary jane belliesa shares how safe nest
is helping first responders identify and
help those in need
january is human trafficking prevention
month and the las vegas fire department
and safeness are partnering together to
provide first responder training on how
to support victims of domestic violence
and how to spot human trafficking dina
d'alessio deputy chief of operations for
las vegas fire and rescue says this will
be a yearly training as firefighters
learn how to recognize the signs the
misconceptions of human trafficking and
much more some of the images that we're
shown actually are very impactful for us
i mean it usually will show branding
the interaction that the firefighters
will have with that person would usually
shows that they're withdrawn they don't
have a phone they seem to be fearful of
the person who's probably 30 feet away
safeness ceo liz ortenberger says
through these awareness trainings first
responders can immediately provide
domestic violence survivors with
resources and shelter we're the third
most dangerous place in the country for
women being murdered by men before the
pandemic but here's the win
we will be
lower in that ranking as we come out and
in a better spot because of our
partnerships with both fire and las
vegas metro while we have seen an
increase in domestic violence incidences
we have not seen the correlating
increase in homicides and that's
directly related to partnerships like
this so the community can help by i mean
there are eyes and ears anytime that
they see something say something
obviously call 911
and will be there to respond reporting
from the las vegas fire and rescue
center mary jane ballieza live local now